You wrote 1. Tadah! All right! So, I hope that worked.
If that worked, let's see if we can figure out how. So what we're really looking at here is a graph.
Even though I had you write your initials, it's just some arbitrary graph that's written in the plane
and we know that it's written in the plane because whenever 2 edges cross each other
we've marked that as a node so that technically the edges don't cross each other any more.
And then we use Euler's formula, which says that the number of nodes minus the number of edges
plus the number of regions equals 2.
But you'll notice that I kind of defined region differently in this trick.
In Euler's formula, the number of region includes the giant region outside.
But here I was just capturing the close regions and so that's why it's 1 instead of 2.
So this should always work.
One of the things that could go wrong is if your initial somehow just have a loop by itself.
So I'm not exactly sure what happens in that case,
but I think that we'd end up getting one additional segment and one additional region.
So as long as you count this as one segment, I think it's okay.